previously when you wanted to compose
music or do music you would have to go
through a digital audio workstation you
have to use a DAW and does have
drop-down menus what is nice about VR is
that it opens up this kind of new realm
of user interactions what I've been
doing with this most recent project
which is the interactive beat drop
simulator it's primarily built around
two gestures which is one the up gesture
which starts intensity rising and then
if you want it to keep rising you have
to gesture up again and then you do it
again and again and again and that the
intensity builds up in addition to this
like the music builds up but also
ideally the visuals around you start to
get a little bit more intense the world
starts vibrating colors start shifting a
little bit choreography happens in the
world around you and then there's a
downward gesture which triggers the beat
drop and that's supposed to be super
satisfying where I chose when that would
happen I did it when I felt it was right
you know I got take take the inputs that
you put in like react to that boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don shotgun we are at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology in
Cambridge in Massachusetts we are now
going to be talking about interactive
audio-visual creation we have Gregory
Osborne joining us on the show hello
hello thank you so much for coming on
I'm very excited this is a topic that we
really have yet to dig deep into very
pumped to have Greg joining us he's a
recent graduate of Berklee College of
Music in Boston focused on developing
the next generation of interactive
audio-visual art using video game music
implementation taking advantage of
virtual reality and new types of user
interfaces and you can find Greg's links
below check him out Greg let's start
things off with this perspective that we
find ourselves as stewards of Earth what
does your current take on the state
our world I find that the recently
especially with with the kind of
advancements of technology we've had
especially in the last half century if
not the last like century itself we've
found that technology has made it way
more accessible for for people who have
no formal training in art or science to
be honest in very many fields to start
participating in those fields there's a
lower barrier of entry because
technology has made it way easier for
for people to one learn what it is
that's important for the performance of
that job whether it's art or science or
whatever but also makes it easier for
them to share what they have learned so
that they can like really expand the
pool of people who are interested in
that subject so for example if I have
found this really cool cheap easy form
of music to create it becomes really
really easy for me to spread that to my
friends so that they can also make that
music and you build up your kind of you
know culture around that where everyone
is sharing it's really easy to share
it's really fast you can do with the
click of a button check out this track I
made check out this art that I put up on
tumblr or whatever it has become really
shockingly fast to to share your
advancements in a field so what I found
is that this does this hasn't
necessarily diminished like the the
value of having really deep knowledge of
a thing because you still can make like
incredibly nuanced and complicated
pieces of art because you have studied
this for 20 years but what it's done is
it's opened up this kind of Avenue where
that's not the only reason to to do art
you can also do it just for your friends
because you got home from work and you
have not been given the amount of like
expression self-expression that you
desired in your day
I'm sure that's relatable to a few
people and they can go home and they can
express themselves with you know their
hobbies and not only it doesn't have to
be alone in your basement that you do
this you can also share it with all of
your other friends you also probably
possibly work similar you know jobs that
don't fully give them the potential to
express themselves and that's not saying
there's any shame in that but what we've
seen is the technology is made way
easier to continue to express yourself
despite you know these kind of primary
activities that you find yourself do it
yes the people that push the edge of
knowledge and build the new tools and
technologies that then democratize
people's creative ability to contribute
is such a great synthesis on the state
of the world I love that let's jump into
the journey so you were raised in DC yes
and then you went to the Berklee College
of Music here in Boston I want to know
tell me about the journey and what
sparks your interesting music well
musically I've been playing classes that
I was classically trained to piano since
the age of five was kind of thing my
parents are like do you want to do this
and I kind of said yes to most of their
suggestions at the time I was five so I
did I found that I really enjoyed it
just playing piano interestingly I don't
really play how much piano anymore I
kind of got sidetracked into composition
around the ninth grade because because
of my like piano playing skills they put
me into the Honors Program at the Levine
School of Music where I got access to
most importantly this one workshop which
was everybody writes a song as a group
and I remember like writing the song as
a group with the lyrics and everything
and I enjoyed that song so much that
when they failed to send that song to us
after the event was over I asked them
multiple times and
I never got it I went back and I spent
an entire weekend rewriting it for
myself it was it was the song called my
GPS lives it was basically comparing
your GPS to a girlfriend like a bag like
a bag girl was like a poor dysfunctional
relationship and so I enjoyed that idea
so much I was like this I want to hear
it again but they don't send us the file
of us singing it so I ended up remaking
it so that kind of started me on the
process composition as opposed to just
playing music and and my father kind of
was a DJ in his in his spare time it's
like as a hobby and so he used Ableton
for that Ableton is this program that
can be used for DJing and it requires a
bit of setup in you you do it and that
was kind of how he performed it but it's
also primarily a music making tool so
when he heard that I had an interesting
composition it was like you should try
this program and so I got that program
and that's the program I've mostly been
using for the past five or so years to
create music hope today till today
tables in Ableton it's a it's a digital
audio workstation and called a da da for
short and you might hear me say heavy
very cool but it's it it's mostly used
for electronic composition so that's
kind of the music that I make right now
is mostly electronic though that has
changed since I came to Berkeley and is
this still with when you were using
Ableton last five years is this really
still the clicking and dragging into
timeline sequences um well one of the
one of the nice things about Ableton
actually is it kind of revolutionized a
new type of composition which was their
not arrangement view which is what you
were mentioned but they saw no range
item interviews there's the arrangement
view which is where you click and it's
linear linear
yes but Ableton also has the session
view which is where you amass all your
clips in like this kind of spreadsheet
essentially and you can program behavior
into its playback so that you can
trigger clips nonlinearly so you can
change your arrangement on the fly based
on the music that you know it becomes a
live performance and so that's what a
lot of people
we use especially now for live
performances for electronic music
because you're not necessarily up there
with the guitar shredding but what you
can do is you can show off your prowess
with all these kind of inputs and like
hardware and triggering the right dials
and buttons at the right time to perform
the piece of music that you wrote
electronically so that's why that one of
the things Ableton's excels at and
that's also partly that's where you can
add a sequence of a couple things and
then have that become a program that
repeat seven yes and you can just loop
it you can have a bunch of clips trigger
at the same time you can design
instruments with like macros that use
specific dials that you adjust to change
parameters live and so it created
basically a new type of performance for
electronic music the digital audio
workstation it's a digital it's a
digital audio workstation it doesn't
most digital audio workstations don't
have that feature that digital audio
workstation mostly just for creation of
music it's just the program that you use
for that and then you can actually get
your your ability to actually do to
perform it live when the what is the
scratch is this what is this oh well
this is like turntables and scratching
this is that's not what Ableton is
mostly Ifill yeah what is what is that
this is scratching a turntable so let's
go so there is an additional potentially
a physical unit that one can use to have
a scratching of turntables as well to do
like a physical kind of yeah anytime you
can record performances of that okay
your that's what would normally be
separate gear though although I'm sure
you can find a plugin that helps you do
that just in the program and did you end
up picking electronic music like around
like when you were starting doing this
and then you kept doing it through
Berkeley yeah it's sort of I I found
electronic music a little bit earlier
then I've had the access and means to
produce it myself but it's kind of just
like my musical tastes evolved kind of
slowly based on the YouTube videos that
I watched and and the the music that
they used in like
Gaming montages was often an electronic
so the particular artists that I listen
to ended up like fueling my my love of
electronic music but now I'm I've you
know gotten incredibly nuanced and deep
as most musicians at Berklee will with
their musical tastes
you know the people make really deep
dives into specific things and I'm not
different yes
and no this is clear guys you teaching
me about cwp which means contemporary
writing and production and this is for
all different types of things film games
etc so teach us about what this major
even is yeah so this is at Berklee
College of Music in Boston it's one of
many majors that you can take here
contemporary writing the writing and
production tends to be the kind of
generalist composer where it's not
necessarily you as a like specific
artist producing and producing music
under your own name but it's for all the
rest of the music that surrounds us in
daily life be it in advertisements in
YouTube videos for example you can
arrange sometimes when somebody writes a
cool piece of music but they need it
like arranged in four different bands
like one for a band one for an orchestra
one for five flutes and a fiddle or
something they generally need they hire
somebody to just arrange that for them
so that's a skill that you learn in this
major it's kind of just like general
writing of music as well as recording it
you kind of it's it tries to be a mix of
a lot of different things and do you
need to know sheet music yes do this so
you need to know how to position musical
notes on on a musical bar yeah and
there's programs that help you do this
and how long they go for and what what
is it an accent accent articulations
like the different types of of notes
that you can that you have soaking notes
that you can interest
yeah and and there's probe I actually
have a friend of mine who specializes in
just getting music onto the page in a
way that's clear and legible Wow so
people will have like you know
orchestral scores or whatever like music
that they have written in their head and
they have like you know this kind of
mock-up and and he will go just into the
program and make sure the score is clean
and all the parts are very legible and
very clear about what they do because
that actually it's a process it takes a
bit of time I have he's actually doing
one right now for me but and that's just
what he does is his specialization
that's kind of a beautiful thing about
Berkeley is that they're all geniuses
but like at very specific things all the
things are different which is kind of
like scorecleaner or like be clean up
just just cuz it's T's it's like it's a
hard thing and there is a certain amount
of art to it to make it as clear and
concise to the player who's reading the
music so that they can accurately
reflect the wishes of the composer
that's not that's not easy
it's Sun necessarily always like just
well it'll happen it does take a bit of
work and effort and a score can be used
for a film or a video game or a
commercial or it's like so many yeah
music is everywhere like people write
music for lots of things there's like
entire libraries just where people can
go it's like I need music for this kind
of mood and you'll just go to the
library and pay for that music really
fast and just use it like that's another
for example option for for Co EP people
is to just write music for libraries
that gets used in Lord knows what place
because there's so many places that use
music but you know somebody has to make
it first and what would a CWP kind of
process maybe look like for give us like
what you would learn and maybe a general
or two like that are important and then
you how you'd focus so it there's a lot
of different paths you can take with
with this major they teach you how to
arrange for specific groups of
instruments like how do you even write
for horns how do you write for Strings
and for
flutes and clarinets and the woodwind
family and how do you effectively use
percussion and you have to like learn
about the roles of this of all these
instruments you would learn like just
basic techniques that have been used in
recent like contemporary music so like
different harmonies how you stack up
harmonies together how horns are used
effectively in one genre versus another
genre how they are typically used like
genre tropes of course you can get cwp
offers a lot of deeper dives into
specific genres that you might be
interested in just to specialize in a
specific type of music writing I
specialize more in electronic music but
especially recently like hybridizing
that with orchestral written music with
live instruments and and kind of
blending that together and that's that's
my specific kind of focus that I did
within the CWG major of course my
primary focus at Berklee was was video
game music and composition for that kind
of medium and so that's that's really
what I've been mostly focusing on of
course Berklee if you take the
contemporary writing in production major
you will be good at writing music like
at minimum so they they teach you that
pretty well but lecture and orchestral
music for video game yeah it doesn't
have to be from video games necessarily
but that is the kind of that's where I
tend to use my compositions that's the
kind of field I'm trying to focus that
your focus was yeah you also made it
crazy interesting that you have to learn
how to write four horns and four they
have a stack for the harmonies we have
interesting yeah yeah blending different
orchestral textures is this whole entire
art like wow one of my teachers I was
like just listen to the way he
orchestrated this listen to the choices
you made and like where'd that in
octaves they are playing or who is on
top of who and how that changes the
character there's a lot of nuance to
everything about music it's not it's
it's not easy
Sarah Lee I need to get great know that
there's so much nuance and I love how
you know you then explain to me early
with in video game music composition
which is where you're super passionate
about there just think there's a huge
difference and thus asar to capture when
we're just you know engaging with
concept we're not necessarily thinking
about how difficult it was to create it
and then you're there but like just like
at a restaurant you don't think about
all the operations in the background
they don't want you to that's also kind
of similar to video game music you don't
want to make it obvious what the systems
are behind it
right the mostly most of the time the
purpose is to just have it just happen
to perfectly score what it is you're
doing like you want it to be subtle like
so I don't want to be able to double
click in and investigate when you wash
yeah and that's kind of like that's the
stuff that videogame composers will do
when they play a game it's all
deliberately try to break the music
playback just to see how it works but
under normal gaming circumstances you're
trying to make it just so that it
happens it happens magically and without
anybody noticing it as gorgeous of the
way as exactly you you meet this really
clear to me I was like holy crabs is
crazy so like when you make the score
for a film the all the music is linear
and then when you are making the the
music library for a video game there's
what's the sound when the door is open
what's the sound when you enter into a
shower there's like yeah this is really
complicated when do these things play
how how are these categorical Ogden Brad
did you create them in the first place
what how do they all the algorithms and
math work as well is about this very
well there's uh there's a lot of
different parameters often that you have
to to take account for one of the kind
of most basic building blocks of the
music part of video game music
implementation is the loop so you have
music that will continue indefinitely as
long as you need it to because one of
the key defining features of game audio
is that you have you can't make the
do a thing most of the time although you
can't you can't sometimes script things
and there's some games like art games
for example that like have specific time
to moments that but normally want them
to feel natural like it feels like a
narrative progression that that a made
sense but often the time you'll you'll
you'll be defining how loops transition
into each other and with what music and
how fast how reactive so for example in
some cases where you have a bunch of
pieces of music that are all the same
tempo you can kind of define the
transitions so that they always happen
on the beat so it always makes sense and
you can also add on top of that another
piece of music that plays to kind of
mask that transition so one very common
trope I hate to ruin games for you now
is a cymbal swell which is and on the is
one of the music changes and and stuff
like that that's generally called like a
transition segment or a stinger a
stinger is more of a thing that happens
at any point just a piece of music that
plays when you either like open a box
like in Zelda so that's like a stinger
that just plays at any time there's a
piece of music but there's also sadness
and an algorithm so it's actually
attached to the treasure box yeah so
when you open that dad's and when you
play that so you don't have to define
either if it can be like opening a box
it could be moving from location to
other learning insurance to another
scene yeah change the music yeah and you
don't know it you don't always know
exactly where you'll exit from the last
piece of music unless you specifically
defined that so it has to be a
transition to make it kind of it doesn't
it doesn't have to be smooth necessarily
you know there's there's perfectly valid
places where it just fades out and then
fades back in again that that is a
perfectly like naturally but the
artistic decision of where that's
appropriate versus where you really
to keep the pace going versus where you
want them to like notice often the
distance like a piece of music that is
directly spatialized to that location
like ah that's a place I want to go to
that is a kind of that often will like
be tied to the specific piece of music
that you're playing it might not even be
heard ever but if you get close to that
location you'll hear this new layer of
music on top of the music that's already
playing and that is defined by question
yes okay so if when we are when we're
moving more towards the surround sound
and then to the M the Sonics these
360-degree places you so we're saying
that there's potentially gonna be let's
say a building that has some sort of
music that's coming from it and we're
hearing it like in art in our inner
background and then the closer we get to
it so it's always playing that building
in the video game the music is always
playing but it's spatially cooked in
that location Location so that way I can
wow that's some complicated stuff to
know how loud to play the music and
that's not how close the character is
that's part of the mixing process so a
lot of game audio implementation is
playing the game a lot to make sure that
that layer of music isn't drowning out
all the other pieces of music that might
also be playing maybe as you get closer
to that building you encounter enemies
and suddenly battle music plays or
something or gunshots happen and you
have to make decisions as to what you
want to be the focus like do you want
the building's sound to be the focus or
do you want the bullets whizzing past
your head to be the focus or all those
kind of decisions are part of what makes
up a general kind of game mix for for
the non-linear music and often you'll
have competing sources of music that's
like there's battle music but there's
also this exploratory music that has
this radio playing or whatever and and
there's the kind of difference between
music that kind of just plays under
score and music that's specifically
sourced in the game that you can that
you know where it's coming from the same
thing for kind of like sound effects
like there's some sound effects that you
need to know the position for like you
where enemies are versus getting hurt
that's kind of an internal thing like
you're getting hurt so you don't have to
worry about where that's coming from
you know where it's coming from here
that just happens in 2d and so you can
just play that directly into your ears
and you don't have to route that into
whatever spatial eyes are you using for
for all the positioned sound effects it
seems crazy thinking about every step
that you take makes a sound in a game so
useless thoughts are like a meme why
every person who does video game sound
effects has to make footsteps it's like
a part of almost yeah so like either you
have your library of footsteps that you
just use on everyone but what if people
will notice so then you have to change
or find different footsteps when you're
walking in grass versus on yeah there's
a lot of different materials sometimes
games have like metal and then glass
that you walk on or have different than
maybe you wade through a river and when
you wade through river you have to make
sure that the footsteps start getting
wet and then fade out completely as you
start swimming and then as you get to
the end of the road so we can't always
just be playing you have to define those
States this is crazy so give us an idea
of how many Audio designers work on an
engineer's work on just a single complex
video game like a sandbox potentially
okay because there's different layers of
video games right there's like indie
games which are generally smaller yeah
which sometimes work with as little as
like one audio person because you know
they don't have the budget for a
composer and a sound designer but like
Triple A games will have like blocks
like you know many sound designers
working on the different footsteps you
know especially if you're on a tight
schedule
you know you you have to organize a
structure whereas where the creative
vision is being explained to the one guy
at the top he's like alright I don't
like that sound effect because it's too
magical and we're too much in a sci-fi
universe so try and change that they
have to make those creative decisions
and
kind of have their teams working on
either footsteps for characters
sometimes one one you'll focus on one
character and all the sounds associated
with them things things like that so yes
there's there's a lot of people working
on sound that's an important part of the
game it makes a massive impact on your
enjoyment of it especially if it's
poorly implemented then you're like ah I
hear that sound again and again and
again and it makes me tired and not want
to play a game and there's a composer
and a sound designer um it doesn't that
doesn't there's no where is it written
that that has to be the case but it
tends to divide up on bigger projects
better if you have one person working on
music and one person working on like
making all the individual sounds and
they'll probably work it together very
closely to make sure that the general
vibe is is similar and and and and
meshes well often they have to choose a
key to make sound effects in to make
sure that harmonically it doesn't kind
of clash too much especially for the
more pitched sound effects that you
might have in a game so they they work
collaborate together but there's a lot
of work that has to be done so they do
separate it out often into like music
writers and then there's their team of
editors that goes through and and
through all the either recordings of an
orchestra that they did to make the
music or the session file the thing if
it's electronic music for example
they'll get the actual file and they'll
separate it into different layers that
can play at different times because
layering is a very common implementation
technique for video games where it's
like you want to build intensity will
just add the music in and then we add
the third level of music in and again
the fourth one oh my god you're
succeeding so much but but somebody has
to go in and like divide those and often
you know a composer especially for
larger games a composer will just write
the music record the music have a like
have a mixer mix it and then you have
like a team of editors who go through
and make decisions as to what goes on
what layer at what time
how to implement it yeah
and the way that you're teaching us
about the video game music composition
is so similar to the video game that
we're in right now because there's cars
on Memorial Drive back there that we can
hear there's people that walk in and out
of the doors in the hallway right now
that slam in and out when you walk you
hear the footsteps there's just this is
such an interesting sort of world of all
yeah glad you give us this perspective
because we don't typically just you know
think about all of the different noises
in the kitchen all the different noises
in the office yeah but it's you know you
can take some time to think about that
like nothing is stopping you from from
just like sitting in a place and being
like what do I hear right now and that's
often an exercise that they ask us to do
I just love that actually because
because often in video games the things
that really sells the world and really
sells immersion is like a bunch of tiny
little details about the room that when
you notice them you know it's like wow
wow especially in the sound design for
example like when you build us like us a
sound like a sword
like hitting a person right you have to
try and put in as much detail into that
sound as possible so it's not only the
swish of the sword and the collision of
the sword on the person but sometimes
the enemy that you're hitting is going
to be wearing armor and so you have an
armor sound or it makes a different
sound when they're not wearing armor
because you broke it or you also want to
have a different sound for it if it's a
bleeding you know sort it it causes
bleeding or poison or whatever you can
add that kind of sound effect on top of
that based on the type of weapon you're
using if it hits the center of the blade
versus the typical yeah and that'll be
more important as we go into VR because
often in video games you don't
necessarily have that direct control
over an object in the south
creates but as we go into more physics
based kind of virtual reality games how
sound is created and propagates becomes
even more important so like where the
collision happens on the sword becomes
important you know so that you can when
you playing the Clank happens from there
if you like if the sword have like
collision is right here you want it to
happen here and not on the tip of the
sword or at the handle you need to make
sure that you position the sounds where
they would be in real life and a lot of
that is it gets more complicated as you
get into virtual reality because the
halves fix from the vibration I mean
this has a robot II the space you notice
the failures of sound implementation
more maths you know it's different when
you're looking at a 2d screen and you're
like oh there's an enemy over there you
know in that general direction then you
move your mouths to look in that
direction and it did pan so that it's in
front of you but but when you're in VR
it matters not just what direction it's
coming from it matters the elevation
it's coming from yeah it matters what
objects are around it that how the
reverb works how the sound kind of
echoes and reflects off the room so for
example this way you can hear a bit of
reverb especially when we talk a little
louder and that's because we've got
glass here and got glass on the other
side and it kind of just bounces back
and forth for a bit and it makes it
sound a little bit more alive than it
would be in in a room that was like all
carpet and so especially as you go into
VR which is why people put up the
soundproofing for example a vent the
reverb for yeah but but as you go into a
game the kind of environment that you're
in if that footsteps sounds like it's in
a completely dry room you know but
you're in a cavern or you're in like a
church you know you want that footstep
to have the same amount of reflections
as it wouldn't that real
space matters even more if you are
denied does it there's a couple of real
to measure you've see you loo if them
maybe take like a boom mic to a church
and then maybe record it that way versus
like animal feel but you'll do that
that's called convolution reverb where
you like fire a gun or more commonly now
you have like a kind of sine wave to
measure how all the frequencies reflect
off the space that's convolution reverb
that's for like really accurate
representations of one position in space
what's interesting though is that when
you make that measurement and let's say
you're in the center of the church the
reverb is gonna be different when you
walk over to the wall wall and then when
you walk up to the altar you guys are
crazy how do you do this so one way is
to let you do the calculations using Ray
casting which is this thing where you
like a fire array in all directions
often one of the games that does this
really well is the last of us they have
their there there when somebody talks
and walks behind a wall then the reverb
changes based on where you hear them
another game that does this incredibly
well is Rainbow six siege is this it's a
it's a shooter team-based shooter and
then but it's it because the environment
is destructible around you it becomes
really important that the sound
propagates to that environment super
realistically otherwise if you're
standing next to a wall like if I'm if
there's a wall right here and there's an
enemy on the other side of it and
there's a door right here when the enemy
walks by I should not be able to shoot
him through the wall based on sound
alone I need to hear that sound through
the door over here so that's where I
hear so I can tell that there's somebody
in the hallway but I can't necessarily
tell that they're right next to me
across from this wall and meanwhile
someone on this side of the building is
breaking down yeah oh and especially
it's like on the third floor a massive
explosion happens you don't hear the
explosion you hear a bunch of reverb
from that explosion and you can it
positions itself from the doorway from
which you would hear that okay we have
we
we expect so much I'm talking about this
spring I'm probably called the cave dope
you handle to doubt about it and you'll
realize I think you'll actually end up
teaching us more about it as we get a
little deeper right some of the hardware
and software side of things which all
right let's dive into this so you're
very interested in making albums of
interactive music so yeah and and I want
well having explains but you know we're
talking about how to make this video
game music composition this requires
hardware this requires software this
things like unity unreal also all the VR
hardware a our hardware is this now out
there but this this albums of
interactive music thing this kind of
loops us all the way back to the
democratization right so teach us about
this and how you're building this well
take for example unity which is free to
download and you can make a game in
unity for free and if it like achieves I
think a certain amount of success they
have they take a cut of that basically
but if you want to learn how to make
games you can just download unity and
make one using the tools that they've
got there and there's also a large
amount of free assets on the assets
store on unity that you can use to mess
around with and see what it would look
like if you made a game like this or
like that and and that kind of that kind
of experience to be able to just like go
out use it of course it's good for unity
because if you want to make a big game
you've developed all these skills and
you're used to this particular engine in
the way that it works so of course when
you make a big game you're gonna be like
yeah I'm gonna use the thing that I know
how to use of course you can also take
it as a challenge to try and do it in
another platform like unreal or a game
maker or there's a couple of tools out
there that you can you can use to make a
game but the entries do you have enough
space on your hard drive to download
this program and then go mess around
with that but cloud is now in effect or
not yet the computations I'm not sure I
that's not really my I don't know much
about that and it's
Sara Lee hopefully I said when it gets
so democratized you don't even need a
really powerful hardware yeah you can
just yeah it will happen at some point I
imagine but in addition to that there's
AI there's sound implementation and UV
that you can do and one of the things
about unity is that if you know enough
coding you can make you can set up some
crazy things and people will sell
packages that they made to do stuff that
you that would be very difficult to to
make just coding yourself but you can
just go out and get a package that does
that thing in unity for you but one
thing that you can do is from an audio
perspective right there's a couple of
programs that are middleware audio
middleware engines that essentially take
the audio functionality out of unity and
just put in a different program and then
those tools are designed to be much more
efficient like from a user perspective
it's like I want this thing to loop and
then every time it loops I want to make
sure it plays the reverb tail at the end
while still starting at the beginning
that's difficult in unity because your
leaves have to be perfect and you have
to have the reverb tail from the end of
the song at the beginning of the song so
that you don't hear a click but if
you're in wise there's really easy to
setup you just put the beginning marker
you put the end marker of what you want
it to loop in between and then all the
sound that comes after that it just kind
of continues playing as it goes to the
beginning so it makes it easier this is
why if there's also F mod I think audio
middleware interesting these integrators
there that's so cool that there's now
markets for that yeah
and also it's I want to see something
that makes it easy to be able to like
you said to take it take what you have
is your current audio in the unity out
and then bring it in with the middleware
that you use I just want it to be more
frictionless too many times we hear
about people that yes that's Lewis
yours worth those work because of
software updates or whatever I mean it
it does take a bit of time I had some
embarrassing long amount of time before
I got wise community to work together
because of one step that I missed in the
process of just getting sound and that's
kind of a thing I've gotten used to
especially because I work in kind of
newer VR spaces as I often just build in
five hours of time at the beginning of
every project to have nothing work and
frantic googling to try and figure out
why the project won't even load like
that's just kind of what I've come to
expect that's but but it it a lot of it
is like YouTube tutorials online that
you can just watch and about the
companies will put up there and you just
watch them and then you're like oh
that's what I missed
I'll just go and do that and then the
sound works and then you kind of build
up honestly YouTube tutorials are the
most underrated source of learning in
this world and mentors one-on-one yeah
yeah I I just for example I just sat
with a friend of mine through for a
class has to implement wise indeed
together and in that process we ran into
one of these bugs that it wouldn't
generate a sound Bank format or we
didn't know how to get it to do that so
it would only work on Windows but not on
the Mac that we were using at the time
and so struggling through that process
and just like banging your head against
the wall just trying to figure out why
it's not working that is very common but
it it it doesn't happen again every time
as in like once you figured that out you
get you get further it's like a video
game you get further and further and
further assume unlock the skills you you
have the keys to unlock that door and
then you know the puzzle that you have
to solve for that door and you know the
quick shortcut through the Dark Souls
level that skips past the first boss and
you get better at at developing games
and implementing audio and whatever it
is you kind of want to do and what's
nice is that there's an often entire
communities dedicated to helping you out
which it just makes me feel so at home
it's like ah yes like I had this exact
question thank you for explaining it to
me in 15 minutes it would have taken me
literal hours to figure that out if you
hadn't done that
correct you know yes yes and I want I
want you to give us the you know this
ties us into the the fascinating intro
music systems that non musicians can
exercise creative control over this is
the albums of interactive music right
you gave some beautiful examples of
being able to build up the beads yeah
and then drop them yeah and the spatial
it an interactive beat drop simulator
the idea of being that previously when
you wanted to compose music or do music
you would have to go through a digital
audio transition you have to use a DAW
and does have drop-down menus and does
have their events like significant
advancements in trying to make it as
easy as possible for non musicians to do
what they want with audio in these
Davonte workstations a Garage Band has
like a bunch of behind the scenes stuff
that it does to your sound like adding
reverb to it and creating busses for you
when you create a new track and it it
really tries to make the process as
simple as possible but ultimately making
music that you would like is difficult
it takes a bit of practice and
investments of time that not everybody
necessarily has although I would
encourage you to invest that time to try
and give yourself some amount of
self-expression but what is nice about
VR is that it opens up this kind of new
realm of user interactions where where
you put your hands and how you move them
can be
used in a kind of more natural way I
suppose um then like using a mouse and a
keyboard to kind of click around it like
music amazing music happens that way but
you do kind of have to know to some
extent what you're going for a lot of
people who start out have like music in
their head they know they want to make
but they don't know how to do it and I
still run into that problem right now I
beatbox music that I know I would not be
able to make in the amount of time it
takes for me to beatbox it's like I this
is the song I want to go to Peru you
know I want to do that I would like now
probably take me 30 minutes an hour and
and this is me having like five years of
music experience to just recreate that
sound that I just made like it's clear I
can't just use bad words and um capture
you doing it and then import it yeah
well you can you can capture that what
I've been doing with this most recent
project which is the interactive feet
drop stimulator is while I'm trying to
figure out the music system I've been
just beatboxing the music is so when I'm
playing it right now it's just me
beatboxing Arizer so the the way it
works is when you it's primarily built
around two gestures which is one the up
gesture which starts intensity rising
and then if you want it to keep rise and
you have to gesture up again and then
you do it again and again and again and
that the intensity builds up in addition
to this like the music builds up but
also ideally the visuals around you
start to get a little bit more intense
the world starts vibrating colors start
shifting a little bit choreography
happens in the world around you and then
there's a downward gesture which
triggers the beat drop and that's
supposed to be super satisfying where I
chose when that would happen I did it
when I felt it was right you know I
whistles that take take the inputs that
you put and like react to that
this is this is not composition right
this is me creating an experience for
you that you can play back you know and
I compose the music so that it would
sound a dramatic and I made the system
in wise so that it would you know it
would time it to the beat so that no
matter when you drop down it'll always
happen in time and things like that but
as I as this kind of field advances of
using gestures to make musical
flourishes when you completely and then
when you when you select specific items
or if you point especially as we lose
the controllers and move towards just
knowing what your hands look like you'll
be able to more and more easily create
an experience that you just dance music
into being and it can be to something so
you can have it be random a lot of work
will be put on defining what some
gestures are teaching people what the
teaching new users what gestures they
can even do like I want you ideally to
experience all of the cool stuff that I
made but to teach you how to unlock
those gestures there's a you know a
certain amount of time that you would
have to invest into learning how it
works and whatever and that's mostly
just art but I hope at some point the
kind of boundaries become such that you
feel as if you are an integral part of
this composition you know that you you
chose these things when the B drop is
playing back you make some decisions to
put effects on top of the digital signal
processing or you you can smack objects
that appear in front of you that
temporarily play one like piece of music
instead of the music you would be
listening to otherwise to to give them
tools so that they have as much control
over what they listen to as possible but
it still sounds good no matter what they
do yeah that's a huge part of it yes and
then you're also moving o to be to build
an album so it's the beat drop is just
one of many then I can do
Sommersby drop or share it with other
people make it social there's so much
and there's there's other ideas which is
like just a gesture based remixer where
no matter what music is playing when I
do a gesture it'll either mute it or
I'll go what or I can like chop it up a
little bit I could like make a gesture
to repeat it over and over again and so
for example I have I had a little bit of
experience teaching kids in they got
access to a studio as part of the Boys
and Girls Club there's a music clubhouse
thing
so they got access to a studio and what
they wanted to do was not compose music
as much as they wanted to rap over it
you know they would go on YouTube and
they would download free me they were
just youtube to mp3 and then they would
go into the pseudonym this rap over it
and they would share with their own
friends you know that's who they did it
for they did it to show off it was like
to show the bars that they had but what
if there was a really easy way for them
to not only just RIT like not there
already is an easy way for them to
reviews it off of youtube but what if
there was a way for them to exert
creative control over that music what a
space showing in a spatial environment
where they could perform it and possibly
record them so no doing that like put it
on social media this is the bar that I
do and in addition to those gestures
that change their music they can also
change the visual environment around you
they can record that and make creative
decisions based on the visual
environment that that oh this is all in
your roadmap vision roadmap isn't like a
long way down I am but one person and
hopefully the the projects that I do and
release I intend to make a youtube
channel dedicated to how did I do that
this is how you do it
we don't show you quick 15 minute video
how do I set up this B drop simulator
yes you know quick 15 minute video how
do I make it so that the visuals reacts
to the bass drum in one way but reacts
to the higher frequency snare drum in a
different way so that when I give them a
drum set with a bass in a snare the
painting
cut the visuals are reflected based on
that so you know and whatever music is
playing in Turkey so how do then make
and build on top of where you've been
pushing for I'd be space I love this
this is one of the biggest futures of
like the way Millennials and Gen Z think
is that it's not just about pushing the
edge but it's about capturing how you
push the edge too and have other people
push it I want to see other people's
better art look at of course I'd like
what I think everybody a lot of artists
will be like like the imposter syndrome
things like what am I even doing here I
don't I don't deserve this kind of fig
and for me it's sometimes it's like that
was like I mean yeah I designed this
cool system but like somebody will make
better music for it or somebody will
make it smoother like the gesture is
it's really clunky right now it doesn't
perfectly sync up with the beat or
whatever or the tools that I'm using
just aren't fluid enough but the hope is
that I will get to experience other
people's improvements on that and I want
to I hope that people make it then
because I
yeah you started walking us through some
of the design tools of the future in
this audio-visual engineering space
teach us about where do you think that's
heading the audiovisual space and even
in the virtual and the spatial space is
off course well I think a huge amount of
of where we're going is is being able to
collaborate in the same space using the
same tools when you're physically
separated and distances and we've seen
this in like conference calls for
example like there's you know you call
in and everybody's in VR and there's a
guy with a presentation at the front of
the room right doing a presentation
that's one way like the Star Wars kind
of hologram effect right for VR where
everyone's sitting around table and some
of them are virtual but in addition to
that I think if if you build up a
community of people who who use the same
artistic tools in different ways which
is a very common experience people use
the same dog like digital audio
workstation and make wildly different
music right but it's difficult for them
to work on the same one because most of
the time there's one keyboard and one
Mouse and one way to input those
shortcuts that you know and like so
often when you collaborate it's one
person inputting all the things and
another person be like what if you did
this drag that onto here and see what it
sounds like try and automate this and so
they're like giving suggestions but
there's not as much of a way to directly
do that thing but for example one of the
things that VR is going to do is going
to if you have a comprehensive enough
set of like gestures and controls such
that everybody can be collaborating on
the same piece of art at the same time
using the same tools then in the same
space for example and talking to each
other in the same space and having all
those tools perhaps like in different
areas so you can tell who's working on
what that can be used for music for live
performances of music even you can use
it for art you know like everybody
engineering everybody who-who like I
have a specific artistic style I use
this brush in such a way and that's kind
of my unique identity is because I've
gotten really good at effectively using
this one tool in this particular way
I think it'll become way easier doom
agnostic collaborations and digital
space everyone has the same tools right
in the same place and they're all
working on it at the same time yeah yeah
right it seems to be such a massive part
of our future yeah yeah I it and it'll
be fun
you know to be able to create with other
people in the room with yeah yeah but
there's also something about the what we
get from the millions of years of I - I
mean so there'll be a balance that we
strike with that for at least a while
we'll see how that is as we get better
and units it were not the hardware is
still and I hope this always stays the
case does not live up to our imagination
of what it could be but it will yet
I assume I hope until you're in
available you know from the physical
environment and then the it'll be easier
to work with other people doing the same
things and and exerting you're kind of
your creative impulses on a piece of
work as other people are doing the same
I hope I hope that happens sooner yes
yes and this is an interesting lead into
our last two questions of course as has
greatly comes digitally
indistinguishable from his physical self
we must ask are we in a simulation are
we in a simulation I mean the easy
cop-out is does it matter
mostly because I mean for me I enjoy
this I am happy with where I am and to
to say that there's something that's
more real than my lived experience it's
like no sure I mean let's say there's
like a Greg that's in a vat somewhere or
something and like with electrodes tied
to his brain I'm still I feel making
meaningful creative changes to this
world you know and I am experiencing
their repercussions
you know I am I'm doing cool stuff I'm
working on cool projects I'm creating
stuff that I don't see in the world
right I'm making those changes and I'm
seeing how they impact the world
hopefully yeah right and in that case
that's meaning to me I don't really need
a deeper one and then the last question
Greg is what is the most beautiful thing
in the world I I enjoy staying in one
spot and just letting things happen
around me in ways that I can try to
come to understand like to sit and just
as things happen be like how how how
does that work you know it's this
happens a lot more with sound than it
does with other things for me but it's
like that was a cool effect whoa what
just happened over there that kind of
thing like how did how did that
reflection occur why is the sound behave
in that way you know how would I try and
imitate that like it so to follow up on
the simulation thing I am in the
business of making simulations so if R
if I was in one how did they do that
yeah yeah right I want to do that I want
to make that for other people like deja
this is how do they do that it's so it's
cool I think it's good there's some
really if you stop and listen there's
some really cool effects that you notice
that you wouldn't have noticed if you
didn't stop love right things like how
do you make love happen in a digital
that you build to love into a digital
world right that's that's separate I
found that outside of virtual reality a
good conversation thank you so much for
coming on the show and teaching us
there's so much to still understand
about interactive audio-visual creation
in general and what the next generation
of video game music implementation
especially with virtual reality and new
user interfaces is gonna be like it's
been such a pleasure thing of course
yeah everyone check out the links below
to Greg's work go and support him also
give us your thoughts in the comments
below on the episode we'd love to hear
from you go and share more content about
these fields with your friends your
family your co-workers online let's get
people understanding the craziness of
video game music implementation and
audio-visual engineering creation in
general democratizing this art and
support the artists entrepreneurs and
organizations around the world that you
believe in simulations links are below
support us as well let us keep coming to
awesome places like Cambridge
do interviews and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world and we love you very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon peace great job brother
woot